everyone is unhappy because they say
they want to be happy happiness I
said it once and I was like you know I
don't know if that's true anymore I was
so against happiness as a concept for a
very long time it's part of my identi
like I'm not a happy person that's fine
stating that got me out of all the
pressure I would put on myself for not
being happy so I was super unhappy and
then I would put pressure and have
anxiety about why I wasn't happy then I
came up with happiness as my Mantra
and I was like I'm just going to do
and then I kind of forgot about
happiness as a concept for a while but I
identified with somebody who wasn't
happy and that that was okay and that
gave me a lot of Peace but then I
realized like a couple years ago I was
like I'm I'm actually pretty content I'm
pretty good I like what I do every day
like I like who I do it with I like what
we do I'm pretty good